we're from Sunrise we're a team of
basically we're a huge company but
inside this company we have a team of 10
people who are really heavily research
focused we mostly focus on everything
that is connected and linked with behalf
behavioral profiling and modeling
behavior of people
with special focus on uh graphs because
we feel that graphs do this task really
well
uh we with our tool that we're gonna
present today we also took part in many
competitions in order to kind of test it
out in a battlefield
and uh we uh we we were on the podium of
many of many recognized competitions and
what I would like to stress here is that
for each and every of these competitions
we used the same tool that we're going
to present so it kind of proves uh it's
it proves that it's really General and
Universal
so why graphs and why we're going to
talk about graphs so basically Sunrise
is working with
clients who operate mostly in business
to customer mode meaning that our
clients themselves have uh like normal
regular customers that do have a lot of
touch points with them like clicking on
the website you know you can think about
retail retail or e-commerce customers
they click they buy something so all of
it can be and we strongly believe that
should be also presented in a form of
graph like their purchases what they see
on their web page how they click
anything that you can figure think of
and it's related to their behavior
yes so now let's dive into cliora our
graph embedding Library
so first to tell you why we actually
need the need cliora we we want to
compute graph embeddings
and why do we need graph embeddings
that's the first question
so if you think about how you can
actually represent a graph in your
computer in order to be able to compute
something or conduct any operation on
the graph
for example to express node similarity
with notes being people or items for
example
first the the first approach that comes
to mind and was actually in use quite a
while ago was uh sort of like adjacency
Matrix where you had the items and users
and they created a large Matrix when
where you had in each cell some kind of
score
showing the quality of interaction of a
given user with a given item so for
example in this slide you can see that
user 1 did something with item one for
example rated it and gave it a five for
example and as you can imagine this sort
of representation grows extremely large
when you have millions of users and you
can have millions of items or tens of
millions of items think Amazon for
example so this quickly grew to
inefficient and right now we use graph
embeddings which are sort of like a
vector which represents the properties
of some node however it can be a lot
shorter than than a row in The adjacency
Matrix for example
so here at the bottom you can see
2D embedding so extremely small it's
just for you for for a show so we don't
use such small embeddings in real life
however you can see that the nodes that
are actually similar in the graph they
are close by are grouped together in the
space and this is a sort of like a
knowledge that is encoded into the
embeddings and right now we'll show you
how to discover this knowledge
so let's start with the graph volumes
that we deal with this is some example
from our company so it's normal that we
can have tens of millions of customers
who generated billions of of nodes and
we need to collect these the the data
over large time spans and the data comes
in various flavors also so at the end of
the day you are left with a huge
database with millions of of data points
with various tables showing for example
including like purchase data click data
and like
um some ratings and so on so forth so
you basically need some sort of graph
embedding method which is really fast
and that's what Clara is Clear Eyes
designed to be very fast and scalable
also very simple which is connected with
the tool
um it supports CPU computation which
means that we don't need like very
elaborate Hardware to start with
and it also natively supports hyper
hypergraph hypergraphs so it's actually
maybe like scary to to hear about
hypergraphs but what we mean here is
that we can easily
process Notions like baskets for example
when certain items are within a basket
so you can see on the bottom of the
slide with the circles uh we can just
show a basket in form of like the pink
nodes which are interconnected with
itself and they create a click so-called
so a structure within the graph when
each node is connected to each
so every user can be a node every
product can be a node every credit card
can be a note and everything actually
can be a node and be processed with
cliora
and this slide it actually shows the
whole algorithm of cliora it's extremely
simple as you can see it's about matrix
multiplication and that's it
so let's see how what it what what it's
about
we start with a graph and we build a
Markov transition Matrix
which is called M here and it simply
expresses which nodes are connected to
each so let's let's see what Node 1 is
connected to well it's connected to node
number two and five so it's a
probability of transitioning from 1 to 2
is half and from one to five is also
half
and this is our transition Matrix and
the first orange Matrix the the one at
the top will be our embedding Matrix so
we start with just random numbers here
and what we're doing here we're
iteratively multiple multiplying The
Matrix M against the Matrix t
so what happens is that each node gets
more at each node's embedding gets more
similar to the embeddings of its
neighbors so if you if you look here
this is the
one to two connection
so
the note number two and node number five
get weighted each by a half and they
start to represent the first number
within the embedding of node one so node
number one will gradually be more
similar to 2 and 5 in terms of the
embedding Matrix
when we have multiplied this for the
first time we need to normalize because
we and and the other times also so after
each iteration we need to normalize
because the the numbers that we're
getting are getting smaller and smaller
so we don't want to get to zero
eventually
why does this work because it might seem
like it's too easy to work well there is
a explanation in the formal formal
explanation at that
there is probably like we want we don't
want to explain it in detail but uh in a
lot of research it's shown that what
we're doing in cleara actually
corresponds to the most important
operation in graph convolutional
networks which is one of the
state-of-the-art algorithms around here
so what we do is the most important part
and you can actually just strip the
other parts and get very good results
now let's go to let's go over to the
competition so another graph embedding
systems which are fast and Powerful in
terms of performance
however you've already seen the
algorithm of cliora and this slide is
just to show you the complexity of
strong competitor which is called
Python's big graph so you can see that
it really like does a lot of various
things it it needs to divide data into
batches for example to really process it
in a fast way it has a really complex
algorithm that wouldn't fit in a single
slide for sure
so there is a huge contrast
however when we
look at the results we can see that you
are is on par with the competitors
for smaller graphs it can sometimes be
be less performant than PPG so the
Python's big graph for example however
for larger graphs it can be stronger you
know it often is and for very large
graphs it is often the only tool that
you can use because others will simply
not handle the size of the data
as regards the implementation well
that's maybe a bit of surprise because
it's a python conference but Kiora is
implemented in Rust however it can be
used extremely easy in python as python
is the I would say main tool for a data
scientist regarding programming
languages so we will just show you in a
moment how you can use creora in Python
cliora has a lot of tricks to make it
fast it uses a bit of
multi-threading it has a magic like fast
CPU access and data locality so this is
actually what is hidden behind
behind this Library compared combined
with the simple algorithm which
inherently is a lot faster than others
it also has some interesting properties
for example you can when you have a new
node that is incoming into your graph
for example there is a new user or there
is a new item which is introduced to
um to the inventory
you don't have the the
embedding computed yet you're not
required to recompute the whole
embedding Matrix but you can simply
average the neighbors because this
simply this creates another iteration of
clear it is a valid procedure here
also it's very easy to just chunk the
graph if it's too big for you even if
cleara is fast and scalable it can still
happen that you just cannot do it at
once for the whole graph so it's very
easy and you will get good results if
you just chunk the graph and then merge
them with again this weighted averaging
which is again a valid
um a value iteration of cliora algorithm
also when you want to kind of slightly
differ the
um the embeddings uh that you get
regarding the function for example
complement versus substitute prediction
in e-commerce you can also do it because
cleara as it as it turns out it's
um Its Behavior gets different with
various combinations of the parameters
foreign
about different embeddings that we can
create but let's assume that we want to
combine a lot of information about one
user so one information uh these are
like his or her interactions but also
each of these projects that she bought
has some attributes and for example we
would like to enhance this
representation this behave like this
this representation of some extra
information so what we could do here is
use uh is use kind of another algorithm
that we also developed for this purpose
it's called MD
uh and I'm gonna explain it in not a lot
a lot of details but in some detail in a
minute but basically what you do what
you can do here is take various
different embeddings like really various
embeddings so for example embedding some
different interactions
so what she clicked what she bought
but also uh for example I know images of
things that she bought so they can be
encoded
and basically what we could do here uh
is use this algorithm
to create this Universal Behavior
profile and how how is it done uh let's
take a look here
we do have uh each of these kind of rows
represents something an event something
that that the user bought so we have
shoes with their corresponding image but
also like the interaction embedding
where the node would probably be this
product right
and what we do here and it's interaction
embedding is like obtained by cliora so
it's an input from cliora algebra
embedding should be obtained with like
super famous algorithms that are out
there like some text embeddings and
birth Transformer whatever you please
image embeddings as well sometimes
probably even the simple CNN work
uh pre-trained CNN
and once we do have all of these
embeddings
um we partition the the space randomly
uh and then we like these embeddings are
kind of they appear in different buckets
and this algorithm this algorithm is
inspired by uh local sensitivity hashing
and account means sketch algorithm
and then uh we aggregate these packets
and it creates a very long Vector that
is handled by us
um via a very simple fit forward neural
network and on the input we do have this
long profile that is created out of
these uh different embeddings
and as an output here actually it looks
a little bit like a recommendation
system setting because we do specialize
in recommendations but it could be
anything you wish so basically you could
do a simple classification here and
calculate propensity for buying one of
the products based on everything that
describe uh describes the behavior of
the client in in your system
[Music]
um
okay so uh there is like cliora is
outsourced it's open source and you can
simply you can easily use it in Python
MD is also open sourced I mean it's
available on GitHub it was used in one
of our booking challenges so it's also
out there we'll send the link over via
Discord
um and let's take a look at some small
code Snippets everything the the whole
notebook is also in the in the GitHub
repo but let's go through it very
quickly so basically we do upload data
from some you know uh you very popular
use case and this data is uploaded in
the uh like node node setup however for
our purposes we need to transform the
input data uh as Basha mentioned we can
like do a star or click expansion
and each of these types of expansions
require different input data you know
I'm pretty sure we're all very well
versed
in uh you're all very well well versed
in Python so you can easily transform it
yourself but this this the the the the
code for this for this is also in in
GitHub
uh and we must end with two types of
files one is for Star extension and it
should be it should be shaped like this
formatted like this and the second one
is for click expansion where basically
you have an ID and you have like other
notes that are linked so all of the all
of the notes are in one row this is the
same data it's just arranged a bit
different exactly
so then once we do have these these
files uh we need to download our clearer
binary from like from the web page from
the from GitHub and it's almost
everything I guess then uh you can use
this very simple formula this very
simple function Trend cliora that of
course uses a process because we like
imported from another another language
I'm going to explain in a second what
these uh what these columns means on
concrete example
so here uh as I mentioned uh we can
train uh two types of embeddings one
with click and one with star expansion
here we have the star expansion and
basically we need to configure the
dimensionality of pleora uh what is the
what would you what would you suggest
would be the best for
uh 512 or 1024 for example yeah so here
we put it here in the chloradem config
then we have uh the number of iterations
that are needed
and then of course uh we put the like
what we want to train and the input file
and where we want to store the
embeddings and they that's basically
that's basically uh basically it's
number of iterations that we kind of
proposed for this uh R5
yeah
and this is another example almost the
same uh but another in a sense that uh
it's uh
uh that it's uh that it's uh for the
star expansion uh and basically you just
you know you just put another file the
one you prepared for Star expansion and
uh uh click uh The Click sorry the one
for you prepared for click expansion and
uh you uh Define that you want to use
the clearer for click
so you would like to use star expansion
when you have a large graph basically so
it it creates less connections
and you can save and compute when you do
store expansion however in our
experience it's uh it gives usually
better results to have click expansion
so a lot of connections so do click
expansion if you can if you cannot do
star expansion
exactly and then oh it's it's not very
visible here but
um or at least we cannot see it super
clearly but what is on the left side the
screenshot from the output that is
created so basically the first line it's
super simple this number of embeddings
and the dimensionality and then in each
and every row you have in the first
place the ID number of notes in the
graph and the most important part the
embedding
and these embeddings can be you know of
the Shelf used for training uh
classification regression whatever
algorithm you please and in the GitHub
repo we also have in the GitHub repo we
also have an example of using these
embeddings I think with logistic
regression or something fairly simple
for classification purposes so you can
take a look if you wish
it's fully reproducible of course and
here here on the left we have like a
umap visualization of these embeddings
we can see that they're create like they
created uh pretty pretty nice uh print
knives clusters and also there are
classification results were pretty uh uh
pretty uh pretty good
uh
uh and that was like about the open
source version
and I know it's used in some of big
companies and researchers from these
companies like they adapted it for their
purposes and they're using it uh in
production
uh but you know sometimes you don't have
time or you don't have resources for
doing it uh and we're also prepared
we're in the middle of and I think we're
almost finishing of preparing uh
software as a service version of cliora
we call it cleara plus with enhanced
optimization certain performance
it's much much faster so if you have
like really lots and lots of embeddings
although El Clara is pretty fast itself
right now
it's optimized for you know production
environment for real companies so to
speak
um we also did a lot of uh amazing
research I might say our because that
was my colleague so I might say it
really
and uh we improved propagation algorithm
and we initialized notes in a kind of
smart smarter way
um
uh we also like allow we kind of
compress these embeddings so basically
at the end of the day you can take these
embeddings and do some kind of a
similarity search or something like that
it's fairly fairly simple
anything to adhere pressure
[Music]
there's this nice feature here that you
can you can start with embeddings that
that express some property of the node
for example if you have a photograph of
an item or a textual description that
you can embed with GPT orbit or
something then you can have this as your
initial embedding in cliora instead of
random initialization so it's really
nice to kind of give it a head start
when it can just learn from a meaningful
embedding already
foreign
if there are any questions I think uh
this is the time to ask them
and thank you for listening thank you
yeah definitely thank you too any
anybody have any questions
foreign
is this feature of starting from
embeddings in the oh well no it's not
it's not
it's it's in the plus version only
however this one is is pretty easy to do
yourself
it's really easy compared to the other
improvements
we just you just replace your your
starting
embedding Matrix from random to
something that you have
yeah so uh I guess if we go back
that would be here right yeah
the the T minus one Matrix is your
Matrix of embeddings you're welcome
foreign
[Music]
just take a look at our website download
it and have a we have some some some
time with it you can use it in your
Enterprise because the license is good
with this it allows Enterprise use yeah
we'll be around on Discord so I know
it's a lot to process
so if you have any questions just
fingers
all right triple thank you and every
everyone's welcome to come to the
Discord as we intend on turning that
into a permanent community and not just
something for the conference
thank you very much and we'll have uh
we'll have our next talk up in just a
couple of minutes you too have a great
day
thank you bye bye